an intensive search continues this
morning for survivors of the deadliest
and most destructive flooding to hit
western europe in years
some of the worst damage is in germany
where days of heavy rain turn streets
into muddy rivers
at least 130 people are dead many more
are missing
european leaders have blamed the extreme
weather on climate change
mts taya reports
as the flood waters begin to recede the
scale of the disaster
is laid bare once thriving communities
now in ruins after flooding not seen in
generations
and amidst all the devastation a death
toll that's
only rising with hundreds still missing
there's
so many people dead
you don't expect people to die in a
flood in germany
you expect it maybe in poor countries
but you don't expect it here
but it was all too fast too quick the
speed with which large parts of germany
belgium luxembourg and the netherlands
were submerged has shocked climate
scientists
despite being among the wealthiest
nations in western europe
their defenses were no match for the
deluge after two months worth of rain
fell
in just two days germany's president
frank walter steinmeier is vowing to do
more saying november
only if we take up the fight against
climate change decisively
will we be able to keep extreme weather
conditions such as what we're
experiencing now
in check in some of the worst affected
areas
emergency crews have started the
colossal task of
clearing the devastated streets of once
picturesque towns and villages
efforts are also underway to restore gas
electricity and telephone services
still cut off for at least a hundred
thousand homes
and as those who live here begin to
calculate the cost of what's been lost
what's clear is life won't likely ever
be the same
now climate scientists have been
predicting for years that
summer rainfall and heat waves would
become way more intense because of
human-induced
climate change but this disaster in
western europe has really just surpassed
all expectations and the fear now is if
nothing is done
it's only going to get worse michelle
all right mts
thank you